this started out as a feature film that
was your intention what changed it yeah
it's what's interesting we had followed
malala's story in the press but it
wasn't until we read a partial of a
proposal for her book before it was
published and it was distilled her story
into about I think 14 pages and it had
so many sort of classical mythic
elements one of the key ones was her
name her name the fact that she had been
named after a famous Afghani woman who
stood up against the British and lost
her life and doing it and it just
suggested that there could be a film and
in her story we expected that it would
be a very small you know independently
financed film but we loved it and
pursued it too when we wet we had to fly
to Birmingham to actually meet with the
family to see if they felt comfortable
with us as the partners and auspices to
make the film and we spent about three
hours with them it was about seven
months after Malala had been shot she
was still recovering but and but was as
powerful as the young woman you see in
the film tonight and we left and didn't
think about it much we thought well that
was amazing they're remarkable but the
next day woke up and said this can't be
a feature this has to be a documentary
there was no way to to cast Malala and
and equally we felt the family needed to
be part of the telling of their own
story so we quickly changed our minds
and and we're thankfully able to pull it
together as a documentary and and Davis
I'm thinking of biopics like Madame
Curie or Joan of Arc or something and
and how do you take especially an
eighteen-year-old girl who's gone
through what she's gone through but give
her texture and reality and not turn her
into a two-dimensional plaster Saint I
have a process when I make my
documentaries that I sort of came to
over time but rather than showing it
people's houses with 15 crew members and
lights and cables and things like that I
arrived at malala's house alone and with
just a microphone and I and the process
and that the the premise was let me help
you tell your own story and so I sat in
her office you know that office with the
post-its with cat-burglar little tiny
room and we sat we talked for three
hours and I didn't have notes I didn't
have a place where I needed to go I just
wanted to pull her out and then I did
the same thing with her father Zia and
from those interviews well first of all
they said we've told you stuff we've
never told anybody because it was just a
quiet conversation and there was no
pressure to be on camera and I think out
of that I think it's that process for me
anyway that makes it feel like I'm
pulling real things out of them and it's
not I think sometimes documentaries are
fighting the Wikipedia page you know you
look up someone on Wikipedia and you get
the four interesting the four not
interesting the four things that
everyone knows and then you move on
and I think especially a movie about
someone who people think that they
already know you want to go deeper and
you want to just pull out those things
and then the other thing is just to
spend a lot of time at you know and a
lot of it was at their kitchen table
when they're teasing each other and
she's looking at pictures of Brad Pitt
I'm kind of embarrassed by it which was
very cute also I went into it thinking
this was going to be a doc about a
person but it was a talk about a family
and specifically about the
father/daughter relationship a man who
says we're we're one soul in two bodies
which was an extraordinary part of this
that I hadn't expected yeah I mean that
was when I went when I went at Walter
and Laurie called me and was one of the
great calls in my life to do this I I
went to their house and I said let's not
make a big
political story I think that's been
dealt with a lot and I think in many
ways it keeps us from from thinking of
the the human beings behind what's
happening and I said let's let's let's
do a father-daughter story I have two
daughters you have one daughter and one
of what my daughter's is a teenager
there there's nine and my daughters are
complete mystery to me and and I was and
part of me always wants like if they
make a movie like I wanted to learn
about climate change I just wanted to
learn about it I want and I start kind
of ignorant and I want to I want to as I
as I as I myself learn about it that
helps me tell the story and helps me
sort of build on it and I wanted to know
how this Pakistani man 7,000 miles away
from me raising his kid that far away
from me how he raised this incredible
girl and and I wanted to know how he did
it so I could learn how to do it and
what about the score because Thomas
Newman did the score but he scored
feature films before yeah and this was
his first documentary and how how did
that get navigated well the truth is is
that that Tom's son of my son play
soccer together do they still know but
he also scored American Beauty for
Laurie he's a remarkable composer but
yeah I think you you talked about it
first on the soccer field no that's just
how I know it but I begged him and and
he came in and saw the movie and it was
a little hesitant you know he's like I
you know I've never done I don't think
he's ever done a full documentary more I
think he's done some openings and and I
said no just was this to do this like
any other movie it should feel like
anything and and and I my daughter my
nine-year-old daughter when I Drive her
to school every morning that's all we
did was play his score and she just
played the part when Malala doesn't
so it you know is in he's just such a
lovely
he's like a true artist and I feel so
lucky to have worked with him what
audience were you keeping in mind for
this because it's about a 16 17 15 16 17
year old a movie for adults though a
documentaries some substance for adults
well I what I make my thumb's III think
I pick an audience that I want to
visualize so when I'm eating kami at
truth I my cousins in Ohio who are
Republicans and I was like it doesn't it
doesn't make sense why would I make a
movie to convince people who already
agree with me like none of my friends in
West LA I don't need to do that I want
my cousin's to be to be to really be
challenged and to change their minds and
for this movie it was I sort of I had a
my we talked about this like a girl in
Thousand Oaks a girl in Japan a girl in
Islamabad and I just in a teenager and
the idea is that they hear about the
story and they bring their parents to
this movie rather than the other way
around and like parents bringing their
children I wanted girls to feel like it
was their movie it was their story and
and and so never wanting to leave them
behind and and and and always wanting to
sort of pull them with me and we had a
screening last weekend in downtown LA
for 6,000 public school girls 6,000 the
theater was so big that they were doing
the wave across the and I didn't know I
was like this is probably the first
documentary a lot of these girls had
seen no boys were there latina
african-american mostly and you could
have heard a pin drop and it and there
was cheering and a standing ovation at
the end and there was and and there's a
sense of like even though this girl's a
Muslim and she's from 7,000 miles away
from her she speaks for them and to me
that that's the most gratifying thing